Um, like, uh, I think that, that our economy, in my opinion,
is becoming increasingly inhuman and punitive and like veering off to like a,
this right word direction. Uh,
and my big goal is to try and humanize it. Um,
and I feel like what you're doing with this human centered storytelling is
trying to drag us in this direction. Um, in a positive way,
I feel like the world needs much, much more of it. The world would use, like,
could you use like a Legion of Sheryl housers,
even though that's impossible because you're like this unique, um,
figure and unicorn. Um,
and one of my goals in having this conversation really,
it was for you to try and impart some of what makes you,
you want to like other folks who want to be you and I'm know,
there are many people listening to this or watching this who are thinking like,
wow, this woman's amazing. Um, so yeah, that, that,
that just wanted to lay out that that was like the, um,
the impossible goal I'd set for myself in this conversation.
Yeah. But Andrew was my profound gratitude for everything you've done in
who you are.
Oh, well, I feel the same about you, Andrew. You know that, but in,
and you know, you say the character chur of you is, you know, maybe that like,
you know, the math guy, but we all know that's not who you are. I mean,
why did you, you, you, you risked so much and you, you know,
you left your family for two years and you like went on, uh,
on this campaign trail because you, you had a calling,
you were driven because you were so empathetic to what you saw
happening in our country. So you, you engaged your big brain to see,
look at the data and see what was happening,
but then you engaged your big heart to say,
I see what's happening and I can't let it happen. I have to take action.
And in your taking action,
you stirred everyone else to follow you in solidarity to change
what's happening. And that's what I try to do with storytelling. Um,
the same thing to, to create action in solidary. But you know, you,
you ask in your book and your, your,
your slogan was humanity first and now your humanity forward. And in your book,
you ask what makes us human?
What makes us human is our ability to love, to feel, to care,
to have empathy, to feel empathy. And, you know, um,
in all of the, you know, there's this, this guy, um, Paul Zak,
who's done a ton of studies in the lab around storytelling and around the
oxytocin and the cortisol, but he, you know, one of his studies,
he would play a video of a father talking to the camera about his son,
who's two and dying of cancer. And, um, and, uh, it,
it follows that hero's journey of the fathers. I have to be strong for him.
And then at the end, and he, he's, uh,
taking people's oxytocin in the beginning, the end, you know,
cortisol that the end of that story, he asks,
do you want to donate some of the money you're being paid to be in this
to a charity that gives money to, um, uh, for, uh,
children with cancer and the higher levels of oxytocin that people
have in their blood, uh, indicated they would give more money. I mean, it's,
and then the people who did give money felt warm and fuzzy after giving the
money and the people who didn't didn't,
which we also know that when we give, we benefit so much,
so this is what, like,
I want to move people in telling stories to have the warm and fuzzy
feeling, and then, you know, and to be fired up to take action.
Um, and you say it all the time, you know,
and which is why you talk about like how dire things are,
but you also give everyone hope you have a vision of what society could be.
If we can tap into our humanity and tap into and get that
oxytocin, flowing, get the, you know,
more of the optimism and the love and the caring and empathy and all of
those things. So it, you know, it is,
it is a self love, begets, love, hope he gets hope.
And we know when people are hopeful and optimistic, what they're capable of,
they can start to take risk and, um,
see their potential and reach for their potential. If people have the mint,
uh, mentality of scarcity, as you talk about there,
all they can think about is like survival it's survival mode.
And then you can't think about caring for others and loving others and all those
other things. So, anyway, I mean,
there is a corollary between what you're trying to do in politics and what I try
to do with storytelling. Um,
then it all comes down to humanity and what makes us human and bringing out the
humanity in us, because that's when we are our best selves.
Um, that makes me really proud that you think we're doing the same kind of work.
Cheryl, let me see very happy. Um, you know, it is about dialing up humanity.
Um, I, I have a question for you then.
I don't know if we've ever discussed this really,
but when I told you I was running for president and I said, Hey,
when you make this campaign video, like, what did you really think?
Um, I remember I'll never forget the moment.
When you told me you were running for president, we were at, um,
an event screening at grand central tech. And, um,
like it was, you had just, uh, sold your book, uh,
the war on normal people. You hadn't started to write the war on normal people.
And, um, it, the people were, were watching the movie and whenever, uh,
we were at these events Greenies together, when people watch the movie,
it was a time for us to catch up, which was wonderful. And you said,
I'm going to run for president. And you know what I said to you,
what I have would say to my children,
when they told me they were going to do things that sounded kind of crazy.
I said, that's amazing. I said, Andrew, go for it. First of all,
because I knew you well by them.
And I saw how you had built venture for America fast. And I knew that you,
more than anyone I've ever met can, will things into being.
And this is also storytelling. The stories we tell ourselves,
either propel us or hold us back. So, you know,
um, we filmed with Cassandra who was born, a congenital amputee,
and her whole life told herself and other people told her,
you only have one arm. You cannot be a nurse. She wanted to be a nurse.
She was told you cannot be a nurse. You only have one arm.
And then when she got onto social media and, um,
saw that there were other people with one arm who were nurses,
if you can't see it, you can't be it. She realized, wow, I can be a nurse.
And when she told herself I can be a nurse,
she figured out how to make that happen. You are someone who tells yourself,
I am going to do this. I can do this. And then you make it happen.
You just will it into existence. And that is also the power of storytelling,
the stories we tell ourselves.
And so when you said I'm going to run for president, I thought, okay,
it's crazy. But Andrew is, he's going to do it. I mean, I,
I didn't think you were going to be our candidate,
but I did think that you were gonna make a lot of noise and that you were going
to reach your goal of making universal,
basic income and automation and all the things. And, uh, you know,
looking at a different way to measure progress in our,
in our society, that you were going to make them part of the public
discourse, um, throughout the campaign and onwards. And so it,
you know,
you really have done that and you continue to do that through humanity forward,
which is, and yang speaks and everything you're doing. So, um, again,
what did I think, I thought this is so bold. This is so crazy.
If anyone can pull off success, whatever success is going to look like,
it's Andrew. If anyone has the guts to do this, it's Andrew.
And when you call, when I remember when you asked me to do the video,
you called, you got my voicemail and you left a message and you said, Hey,
Cheryl, it's Andrew calling. I have a favor to ask, can you call me back?
And I knew, it's like, okay, Andrew wants me to make his campaign. I know it.
I just knew it. And I thought I am honored.
I would be honored. That's what I thought. I, Andrew.
Well, well, you definitely, uh, delivered, you know, you called back and said,
yeah, let's do it, which I was endlessly grateful for because, uh,
you didn't have much to work with. And like,
we weren't paying top dollar or anything close to it. It was, it was just a,
yet another labor of love. Um,
and I hope you felt proud of everything that happened thereafter,
because I genuinely think that, uh,
it might not have happened if not for your belief in friendships. So thank you.
It would have happened,
but I was honored to be part of that journey and to be part of helping,
you know, you, uh, you start the campaign. I mean,
yeah. Uh.
So, um, so if anyone wants to see your work, uh, where should they go?
Uh, well, uh, they should go to creative breed.com and,
um, I have to update it because, uh, some of my recent work isn't there, but,
um, and generation startup is generation startup.com.
And we were on Netflix for two years as you know, um, no longer,
but we're still on iTunes, Amazon, Google play YouTube,
voodoo hoopla to be, I mean, generation startup is widely available. Um,
and still moving people.
You should. My, my cousin, um,
sent me a picture of my face on the monitor of
the airplane seat in front of her,
because she was watching your movie on a plane being like, Hey, look,
look at this. So the movie generation startup is indeed everywhere,
and I'm sure it is, uh, moving people, um, all over the world still to this day.
And I know, um, we're just getting started.
There are so many stories to tell and we do have to do everything we can to try
and humanize, uh,
this land right now because it needs you more than ever. Um,
so thank you for everything Cheryl and I,
and thank you for helping make me more human.
I genuinely had your voice in my ear, the entire campaign.
Like I was like, yeah, sure. I would say show, it'd be like Andrew, you know,
you still have to try to, um, express your humanity.
So you should know you had a big impact on me. Yeah.
Thank you. I think he, I think it was the natural evolution, but I appreciate,
I hear you and I, and I appreciate the things, but, um,
you know, watching you for me, that was so what I was most proud of,
I mean, just to see you grow and evolve, um, you know,
you were always incredibly human,
so it wasn't like you weren't human and you became human. It's just,
you allowed yourself to express that more and more and more, you know, as you,
and now, you know, I think you're, you, like,
you just are so comfortable in that, in that thing in place.
Well, thank you. We have to unlock and, uh,
elevate people's humanity. I feel like, you know, in a way what you saw with me,
I think we need to activate more people. Um, you know, uh,
like that process. And, and I think,
I genuinely think our economy and our culture have put us many of us in boxes
where people just feel like they have like a narrow role to fill or like a
narrow set of things they can express. Uh,
and that if you can let them out of that box, uh, then the sky's the limit.
I feel like that that's what your work's about. Um, but yeah, like it's,
I learned a lot, uh, and we are just getting started, as you said,
and you're going to be there every step of the way I'm going to call you next
time. But this time we'd have more to work with. I'm sure.
Thank you for listening in. I hope you enjoyed this conversation. If you did,
please do subscribe to yang,
speaks and click on notifications so we can let you know every time we have a
new episode.